I was I would say disillusioned
disenfranchised upset nauseated to sign
onto my Twitter it was sometime around
Christmas cuz I actually remember seeing
this I remember what I was when I saw
this the first time I was at my parents
house so it might have been Christmas or
Christmas Eve or something like that and
there's before you get to this Troy Kwan
[ __ ] legs
Thank You Man not either oh you mean Oh
Jeffy uh McAfee McAfee there's a go up
to the the second video down after the
folders there you go
there's a wrestler that I've known for a
long time oh right yeah oh you know the
guy very well his name's Joey do you
know I've had the man in my house
really but he now wrestles for I forgot
about this of course she didn't wrestle
I didn't he wrestles for a promotion now
called aew which is on TNT it's a big
deal and he's a big deal in that
promotion but he also likes the Internet
yep he likes to do things on his own
apparently I found out the hard way that
just because Jim you're vacationing in
Italy doesn't mean the work has to stop
oh by the way this was my house Oh what
that's my house okay but were you still
doing this in Italy every day just tell
me this was there a special luggage that
went to Italy full of chip hats and wigs
yester was carry on your carry on was
all chip stuff that's right because you
can't lose it can't lose the glasses and
I like to have different hats so again
it's a different look but this was a
cameo I book by somebody Joey did he
book it he put it on his own Twitter
yeah no no he retweeted it somebody else
booked it I don't know man I think he
booked it himself I don't know
I'm quite sure he booked it oh okay I
think I didn't talk to him about it we'd
you know I mean I should ask yeah but I
was under the impression I believe he
booked this I'm sad I didn't enjoy
seeing this on Twitter yeah this is chip
chip person doing a cameo for a wrestler
that I know named Joey I didn't I never
heard of him of course not who's this
bad boy Joey janela what's he of Russell
or something
you know I'm looking for somebody to
wrestle I'll leave you leave my glasses
and my hat on and you won't even knock
them off Brendon I do really good
wrestling promos hey there hey there bad
boy Joey janella you're such a bad last
look someone in a wheelchair could take
you in a wrestling fight I'm such a good
wrestler that I could out wrestle you if
I had my pecker tied to my teeth damn
Joey I'm such a fine wrestler in
comparison to you I would pin you 22
times over these are pretty good promos
right
free of charge normally chipper wants a
lot more money for wrestling you have to
you know it ghostbusters when they say
never cross the streams that's what's
happening here for me
my streams are being crossed and now
you're sitting there saying I can't
you're acting like you're being tortured
you're doing everything you can you know
how to do I go on I try to create
content independent of this show I go on
my YouTube channel right and I do my Sam
Roberts now shows and I did like three
of them or something over break and the
deal is that when a super check comes in
on YouTube when I do my shows on my
YouTube channel all the super chats have
to get read you know what kept coming in
what where's the chip mug I thought it
was gonna go on your desk it's true
that's what was coming in there right I
can't escape it and then I'm like you
know what I won't produce content and
then I'll be away from chip
what's Joey up to what's the bad boy
Joey janela up to there he did retweet
this and then all of a sudden chips on
his cameo yeah and then everybody who
sees that it's going hey at not Sam did
you see this yes I saw yeah I did see I
did see his tweet about so now you must
sit with him yeah cuz guess what as long
as what you just heard was we're not
done still much more oh hey by the way
you know what you get when you're
crossing the Raiders and Joey janela a
whole team full of bad Muslims in
Oakland Las Vegas or Los Angeles I'm not
sure where they're situated but all I'm
gonna say is I throw my hat down and
challenge Joey janella to our wrestling
flight maybe we could do it in a
backyard somewhere maybe we could do it
with karate kicks allowed I don't know
but but I'll leave my hat on if you want
then I'll offer you did you say who what
when he put his hat back on you just go
foot and put his hat back on that what
chip did he likes to do you likes to
make little sounds I didn't mean to
interrupt it we should probably go back
just a little bit that's perfect
somewhere maybe we could do it with
karate kicks allowed I don't know I'll
leave the hat on if you want and then
I'll offer you two million dollars if
you can knock my hat off in the first 37
minutes of our wrestling conflict pretty
good huh
is there ever a second take with chip is
it every question like just chip ever
get halfway through and realize it's
just isn't working try a different angle
yeah one more Jim and Sam catch up with
full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM app
[Music]